[Musique]
ims qu'être artiste visuel connu sous le
nom de queen 2
c'est un studio de design 3d
on fait surtout du visuel de chauffe ça
peut être qu'au vu de l'album ce
vidéoclip
la pub un peu le projet interactif sèche
design aussi j'ai quitté l'école quand
j'avais peut-être sept ans avec un de
ses amis sur quatre jeux travers
l'installation aux 40 heures semaine
j'ai commencé à faire de la 3d fujifilm
et merci aussi à l'école pour apprendre
ce domaine là mais jamais été accepté vu
que j'avais pas des bonnes notes au 100
m
le suspens va soir puis j'ai passé un
nombre speed 2 d'argent et si tu as beau
shoot et des problèmes qui est c'est
parti
je pensais plus important c'est vraiment
de s'asseoir puis vraiment prendre le
temps de faire ce que tu veux faire
c'est petit ça soit 15 minutes tout ça
soit 5h10 mais quand même ce temps
affecté dans cinq ans sa vie 15 minutes
à tout les jours mais c'est comme ça va
voir créer quelque chose ne savons pas
de d'essayer puis de lancer 116 jours
que je crée quelque chose à la fois tous
les jours un truc en 3d que je publie
sur les réseaux sociaux facebook un état
grave rich un peu partout et seconde
l'asie qui ne comptent à quatre secondes
de la place à jallet saison la france
quand j'ai eu mes premiers clients
j'avais aucune dit ce que je faisais
était vraiment et ses erreurs
[Musique]
chez un gros flingues l'eau douce qui
est un artiste engagé quand sa part a
trop dit je me suis qui lui l'a un jour
je travaillais avec les jauges et kim
avec son nom en groupe du québec comment
je peux atteindre
je regardais tout le monde qui travaille
avec cette personne le tout le monde qui
sont en contact avec les artistes qui
mettent en contact avec le j'essaie de
faire des trucs un peu détruit
artistique un peu dans sa direction
[Musique]
c'est quand même bien passé ce que la
compagnie qui fait les visuels poplineau
deux m'ont contacté pour faire des
visites ça se passe
[Musique]
james nason dès qu'on fasse j'aime chez
des sujets qui sont plus difficiles à
approcher son siège peu comme mes
marques a drainé beaucoup d'humilité
il faut écouter aussi les gens autour de
toi on va dire une chose ou bien portant
que c'est de collaborer au sipi ne
parlera pas de politique a chance existe
peu la chance d'être sacré